and you're already winning oh my gosh
you're already one you won already
yeah what does that mean add another
grammy to the collection oh my gosh wait
what did i win you won did you win
already right she won already i don't
want anything you had one you didn't win
one all right i thought you won one
already no it's not confirmed oh it's
not confirmed you know what that's right
i am a winner tonight because
manifesting a yes that's a win to be
here is a win yes it is absolutely it's
the biggest win and you i mean
we've come to so many people tonight
asking them because the grammys are
about collaborations dream
collaborations and i say who's your
dream collaboration
i can confirm now you have won best oh
my god yes r b
i'm here to tell you no way yes we won
oh my gosh wow well hey this is a this
is a great game you can give a speech
quickly i can't say that
give the speech all right well i can't
say that i didn't win a grammy today um
and i'm so grateful this song you know
it didn't
it wasn't something i thought would you
know
have me hear you know it's a song that i
felt like was so powerful a part of a
big story that was so powerful and still
relevant to today
and i'm just i'm so grateful to have
been a part of that movie and you know
to
i don't know for people to love the
movement and and be a part of this fight
that i think is ongoing and um yeah it
means the world to me
you made an anthem song mom now that
anthem song has a grammy
what about the performance tell us about
the performance tonight or what can you
tell us about the performance we've had
a sneak peek yeah you got it you got a
little sneak peek but this performance
is going to be so electric it's going to
be so
energetic and fun i can't wait and
there's going to be different chapters
in the performance that's all i can say
i love it
i love it and you know
multi-instrumentalists watch out just
watch out that's all i can say good luck
the rest of
congratulations and everybody who's come
up here says they want to collab with
you
we've had like five people wanting to
collab with you well that means the
world
[Music]